last but not least
got you a pitch pipe
for singing and i got myself one too
because they're awesome
right
it's beautiful
thank you this is
perfect of course i just want you to
have a good first rehearsal and i'll
just i'll be
hanging out until you're done
you must have something better to do
than sit around and wait for me
that is a scene from netflix's tall girl
2 starring ava michelle and lucky for us
we don't have to sit around and wait for
ava because she's right here with us
hello hi
congratulations on the film thank you so
much oh and now that the movie is here
what
types of emotions are you feeling are
you excited nervous i'm so excited i
think it's it's really funny because i
think jody and i have a very similar
emotional journey throughout the first
film and the second film because the
second film she's coming in off of
this huge speech that she did and she's
now confident and she's gained it but
there's a lot of people expecting a lot
from her and i can kind of feel that
with this film as well as like you know
it's as scary as it is exciting of being
in this position and i'm so grateful for
it but it is also very terrifying trying
to create a sequel to something that
meant a lot to people that's a lot of
pressure it is yeah it is but i wouldn't
change it for the world so i'm i'm very
excited with all that being said of the
similarities to your character did you
have an overall very similar experience
in high school did you go to high school
you didn't go to high school
i'm like tall girl has been my high
school experience and i think it's been
pretty pretty great our dances are very
elaborate um no i didn't i was
homeschooled for high school because i
was pursuing this career and
so our high schools were our high school
experiences were very different but i
mean i relate to jodie in so many ways
of the things that she's been going
through of insecurities and her height
and securities um just with herself and
having confidence to do what she loves
so
we definitely relate to each other on a
deep level but wow as far as high school
goes not exactly
you mentioned the dances now
your character is the lead in the
musical you have an incredible voice but
we see a lot of the dance moves too i
was so excited i honestly was so mind
blown when i was reading the script and
found out i would be able to dance and
sing right and tall girl because that's
something that's been a dream of mine
since i mean i started out dancing when
i was two and that was my first love so
being able to now act sing and dance in
a film is just
a dream come true honestly did the
writers know that going into it your
love for dance do they kind of write it
in
like i feel like it could have been a
little bit of something because um i
think if another actor would have had
you know a different skill set that it
might have gone a different way um
but yeah i would never expected jody to
be dancing but her love for music and
the arts i think really just aligned
with you know my love for it as well so
that's incredible this is kind of like a
a dream role for you then it is
honestly i remember booking tall girl i
thought i dreamed big and then i was
like this far surpassed any of my
biggest dreams and being able to be a
part of a film that has such an amazing
message to people and can really touch
people that were going through something
i was going through i think is yeah i
couldn't have asked for anything better
what's so interesting too is
when i was in high school when i look
back
it was a long time ago but
it doesn't work
i don't recall having
movies that i could watch that would
relate to the struggles that we do face
yeah in high school the insecurities you
know
boys all of that why do you think it's
so important to be able to have your
character show even scenes like jody
experiencing a panic attack yeah being
able to portray that on film where
people can watch and be like and relate
to it how how important is that for you
it's incredibly important to me i think
our writers and everyone who's involved
in this project has made it their goal
to be that for people i think you know
jody dealing with the bully inside of
her head and anxiety attacks and also
watching the other characters deal with
the hardships that they're going through
i think it's beautiful for anyone to
relate to i think anyone of any age
struggles with
you know that voice inside their head
telling them that they can or they're
not good enough and so i think
addressing that in any way and making
people feel seen and letting them know
that they're not alone going through
this is just
amazing to be a part of it is amazing
and then on top of all of those
struggles that jody is facing there's
three boys in the match
i'm like this is so much there's so much
going on it's stressful and i'm also
like reading the script i'm like jody
what are you doing what is going on your
life is already so complicated um
yeah it's great jody always is in some
sort of love square triangle yeah
something like that yeah but that's the
that's the only part of of your life
that i feel like is is not similar to
real life because you have a boyfriend i
do have a boyfriend yes but it was a
struggle to get there i feel like for
sure but i definitely never had
four suitors that were ready right there
ever i never did in high school either
either is this normal i i don't know i
guess i guess so for jody it's pretty
great it's very complicated love life
for her very complicated well like we
said at least in real life we don't have
to deal with the complications your
boyfriend is so cute thank you so much
hide a conversation at the very
beginning of your guys's relationship
any chance i feel like height has never
been an issue for me i've always thought
it was only an issue if it was an issue
for the opposite um i think that you
know i talk about this all the time
dunkelman is such a great role model for
for shorter guys because i think if they
are confident in who they are and they
are confident to let their opposite be
who they are then then it works out he
is taller than me my boyfriend now which
is amazing but he's encouraged me to
wear heels since we started dating which
makes me taller than him and
yeah meant a lot it means a lot yeah now
do you think because netflix does this
thing where they have a hit film and
then they make three of them right it
seems to be the number i know lucky
number three i think that's why they say
it right i agree um third one's the
charm uh is that the same yeah so um
but we'll see i mean do i think that we
have so much more to tell with jody's
life and all of these character stories
i do i think we could go on for 10 years
talking about them and yeah and talking
about different messages and truthful
real things that we go through um so
netflix please please do that that would
be great um but we'll see jody goes to
college it would be great she needs to
graduate first it's kind of my thing
listen i think there's a 3 4 5 at this
point there we go it's like jody and
duncan get married
listen that could be really cool for
people to follow the character through
life right it could it could be very
cool so now in the meantime what else do
you have going on yeah um
as you know acting stuff goes we will
see how everything pans out and
but right now my passion is a clothing
line that my mom and i just
dropped it's called identified and it
was actually a project that my brother
my mom and i wanted to start but he
unfortunately passed away almost a year
ago today to fentanyl poisoning which is
something that
is terrible and is taking way too many
amazing people and something that i want
to speak on but his passion was really
just
making people feel good in their own
skin and knowing that they should only
have to be identified as humans and we
can all have just confidence in that and
equality and
um so that's really what identified is
about and we really just wanted to see
it through for him and what he believed
in and
so that's something that's a huge
passion project
of mine that is finally out in the world
which is crazy what an amazing way to
carry on his legacy and i know you
physically carry him with you as well on
your on your neck yeah it's his
fingerprint actually which is also
unidentified the tags are also his
fingerprint as well wow so i just love
it because i feel like he's leaving his
print on people and everything that he
believed in
he was just the most beautiful spirit
what a bittersweet time for you but you
know we are sending you so much love and
congratulations
on the clothing line on the film and
everything you've got going on again
when you want to promote the third
fourth movie we'll be right here come
back here i know i will see you in a
year
okay hopefully maybe two i'll i'll
remember that but in the meantime taw
girl 2 is on netflix february 11th